markus söder ist zugeschaltet aus
nürnberg und wir fragen den
ministerpräsidenten von bayern auch noch
mal nach dem eingangs zitierten
parteivorsitzenden der fdp herr lindner
wirft ihnen im grunde genommen vor die
bilanz zu verschleppen
also da schiebt die große koalition die
bittere bilanz auf für eine zeit nach
der bundestagswahl
nein das ist glaube ich unsinn die
wahrheit ist natürlich dass wir nicht
100 prozentig vorhersagen können wie es
ausgeht wir haben ein paar gute
prognosen für bestimmte branchen
wir haben aber auch ein paar düstere
also man sollte ja in der wirtschaft
nicht schlecht treten wenn man soll sich
das ganze auch nicht zu schön machen wir
haben im automobilbereich im
maschinenbau im luft- und
raumfahrtbereich erhebliche probleme
dort vor allen dingen wo es um den
export geht denn die welt um uns herum
ist ja auch in corona was des wortes
fieber und wir haben erhebliche probleme
mit mancher lieferkette mit märkten
deswegen ist ganz klar die kurzarbeit
hilft und ist ein gutes instrument
völlig klar
aber am ende geht es um nachfrage geht
es um auch produkte die verkauft werden
können und da muss man ganz nüchtern
feststellen da wird es in einigen
bereichen noch schwierig werden die
automobilzulieferer haben massiv bereits
stellenabbau angekündigt auch im
automobilbereich generell wird es
schwierig deswegen glaube ich müssen uns
noch mal genau überlegen wie während
diese speziellen branchen diese
hochwertigen arbeitsplätzen gerade für
die industrie erhalten können da haben
sie dafür plädiert dass man ihnen eben
der automobilbranche als auch bei der
luftfahrt als auch im maschinenbau sogar
noch eine schippe drauflegt wenn wir
gleich noch fragen bei uns ist so
professor monika schnitzer schnitzer sie
sind im sachverständigenrat also
wirtschaftsweise und ökonomen
ich frag mal so hat der nächste
bundeskanzler egal ob er stolz oder
söder hieße ungeliebt tatsächlich
gleiten und arbeitslosenzahlen und
haushaltslöcher im gepäck also gut dass
sie nicht nicht nach dem namen des
nächsten kamera gefragt habe da wäre ich
jetzt echt in verlegenheit geraten aber
machen sie die frage stellen was werden
die vorfinden
dann denke ich ganz so düster wird es
nicht aussehen
wenn wir jetzt die breiten anschauen es
ist ja eben schon angedeutet worden wie
viel war das in der letzten krise damals
gingen die pleiten um 12 prozent hoch
wenn wir das auf die heutige zeit
übertragen würden dann wären das
vielleicht 2000 3000 leiten mehr
das ist tatsächlich nicht so viel es
wird ja von einigen behauptet 20 prozent
10 prozent dazwischen irgendwo sind die
unternehmen alle insolvenzgefährdet wir
haben 3,5 millionen unternehmen das wäre
wirklich sehr viel aber das sind immer
umfragewerte und wenn ich als
unternehmer gefragt weil da geht es mir
schlecht sagen ich natürlich es geht mir
schlecht denn ich will ja noch mehr geld
von herrn scholz haben wenn sie uns
weiter vom steuer und insofern ist das
ein bisschen der blick in die
schneekugel aber wie viele kurzarbeiter
von heute tippen sie sind arbeitslose
von morgen ja wenn wir deine vorne
hätten dann würde ich ihnen die zahl
genau sagen aber die formel gibt es
nicht was wir tatsächlich wiederum sagen
könnt ist nach den prognosen die wir
machen vom sachverständigenrat aber
natürlich auch andere institutionen
machen solche prognosen rechnen wir mit
arbeitslosenzahlen die nicht weit über
drei millionen hinausgehen werden das
heißt selbst die kurzarbeit die wir
jetzt haben die werden nicht alle
arbeitslos werden
denn die wirtschaftsentwicklung die
entwickelt sich sehr positiv und wenn
das so anhält dann müssen wir nicht mit
dramatischen arbeitslosen sanieren wir
noch ein bisschen konkreter machen wir
begrüßen den sechsten gast wie in der
runde aber zugeschaltet aus berlin bei
uns ist ob professor klaus-dieter
zastrow facharzt für hygiene als hast du
es gibt eine interessante umfrage
deutlich mehr menschen in diesem land
machen sich sorgen um die wirtschaft
mehr sorgen um die wirtschaft als um
corona ist dass in anbetracht der zahlen
auch der von heute 2200 neuinfektionen
eine gute idee eine gute annahme
ja ich denke dass das schon eine gute
haltung ist ob die jetzt
wissenschaftlich auf wissenschaftlichen
erfahrungen begründet das weiß ich nicht
aber die zahl 2000 ist natürlich mehr
als vielleicht noch vor vier fünf wochen
wobei teilweise ja auch unter tausend
lagen aber in der ersten welle die uns
ja doch gewissermaßen kalt erwischt hat
da waren die zahlen eben 5000 6000 fälle
von tag zu tag weiter
jetzt haben wir gerade weil sie die zahl
von heute an sprachen die ferien beendet
in baden württemberg dabei sind 14
millionen leute die ferien zu ende
gegangen und damit kommen sie auch
wieder aus dem urlaub wieder
also das heißt das hat natürlich auch
auf jeden fall damit was zu tun dass
urlaubsbedingt auch in andere länder
gefahren wird und anders gelebt wird und
auch ein bisschen freier ja also ich bin
unbesorgt
die kohle ist nicht vorbei dass es
völlig klar aber dass wir noch mal
solche zahlen haben wir wie wir sie im
april mai hatten
davon gehe ich überhaupt nicht aus denn
jetzt haben wir die max maske die hatten
wir damals noch nicht aufgesetzt das ist
einfach drei monate zu spät gekommen
aber jetzt schützen wir uns wenn auch
nicht alle aber die meisten leute setzen
niemals geld drauf und das zahlt dann
auch schon ein das heißt sie befürchten
eben auch keinen zweiten lockdown nein
nein da wäre gleich die frage an die
politik herr scholz ihre parteifreundin
malu dreyer ministerpräsident in
rheinland pfalz sagt ganz dezidiert vor
vier wochen in unserer sendung es wird
keinen zweiten lok darum geben weil wir
ihn uns erstens nicht leisten können und
weil zweitens regionale lockdown
vollständig reichen
warum macht die politik immer noch so
viel angst davor dass es einen zweiten
lok daran geben könnte wir haben eine
ganze reihe von maßnahmen ergriffen um
genau das zu verhindern alles das was
wir tun auch unter gesundheitlichen
gesichtspunkten dient dazu das ist nicht
dazu kommt und natürlich geht es hier um
eine naturkatastrophe etwas das als
virus die menschheit insgesamt
herausfordert und auch uns da sind wir
nicht alleine diejenigen die bestimmen
was sich so alles entwickeln wird hat
das habt ihr etwas damit zu tun aber
tatsächlich haben wir jetzt so viele
maßnahmen ergriffen die wir als
erforderlich gesehen haben um genau das
zu
zb stärken wir uns mit vier milliarden
euro die regionalen gesundheitsämter wir
sorgen dafür dass über personal
eingestellt werden es ist überall
technisch aufgerüstet wurden auch mit
der digitalen aber was immer noch vor
diesem zweiten lockdown gewarnt dass
fragen die auch nach nürnberg
also da wir haben sie sogar so zitiert
weil sie es gestern noch einmal
gezittert haben
ist das nicht ein alarm und schüren von
angst wenn wir zwar höhere
infektionszahlen haben aber aktuell
heute 238 menschen auf intensivstationen
liegen mit krone also schwerst erkrankt
sind
wir sollten uns das ganze jahr einen
schönen reden uns herum wachsen die
zahlen enorm und zwar nicht von einem
tag auf den anderen aber in der
entwicklung und sie sind in einigen
ländern exponentiell bereits wir sehen
es in frankreich in spanien auch
österreich ist hoch besorgt und sie
wachsen erneut wieder in krankenhäuser
hinein also die findet denn nach einer
gewissen zeit beginnen auch junge leute
die weniger krankheits verleben
krankenhaus haben dann wieder die
älteren möglicherweise anzustecken
kärnten ist corona nein das ziel ist
natürlich das nicht so machen klar und
auch die priorität ist die wirtschaft am
laufen zu halten und auch schule und
kita am laufen zu halten
das sind die absoluten prioritäten
übrigens mehr als das reine private
party verhalten beispielsweise aber fakt
ist doch die kernfrage ist corona nicht
mehr so gefährlich wenn dem so wäre wenn
also diese tatsache stimmt dann
natürlich könnte man manches anders
sehen dafür gibt es aber
wissenschaftlich bislang überhaupt
keinen beleg und das ding ist vorsicht
an der frage einfach eine kluge
strategie und deswegen ist auch das
modell regional zu reagieren wie es ist
auch zu recht angesprochen
natürlich das beste beispiel wir haben
uns ja auch in münchen jetzt entschieden
weil die zahlen in münchen ist hat auch
in der tat was mit urlaub zu tun mit
familien heimkehren aus südosteuropa
vielen fällen und begleicht sind mit
manchen party feiern haben wir uns
entschieden wegen einer hohen zahl eben
auch so leid es tut ein fußballspiel des
fc bayern ohne zuschauer
das war ursprünglich noch anders gewollt
da wollte man 7500 zu lassen
jetzt musste die stadt das kassieren und
der auftakt der bundesliga wird ohne
zuschauer stattfinden
vielleicht befassen wir uns nochmal
damit was rund um diese corona gefahr
geschehen ist auch politisch geschehen
ist man kann ihnen auf gar keinen fall
vorwerfen dass sie corona und seine
gefahr unter trittin hätten die zahlen
steigen wir hatten von anfang an
gewandter vorwärmen von der zweiten
welle gewandt wir haben vor dem urlaub
gewandt wir müssen jetzt die zügel
wieder anziehen und sie nicht locker
markus söder bayerns strenger corona
mahner
er gewann in der krise an statur selbst
als der sommer fast vorbei ist hält er
die tonlage corona ist wieder folge ein
deutschland deswegen müssen wir uns
dieser herausforderung stellen
doch strenge macht angst und angst
bringt keine kunden in die geschäfte
keine gäste in die restaurants die
wirtschaft nicht in schwung
haben die politiker fehler gemacht man
würde mit dem wissen heute das kann ich
ihnen sagen keine friseure mehr
schließen und keinen einzelhandel mehr
schließen
das wird nicht noch mal passieren die
strenge hatte ihren preis
also versucht der staat mit
steuermilliarden den lockdown schaden zu
beheben ist das bereits der nächste
fehler
der finanzminister hat zurzeit das
geldhaus als gäbe es kein morgen mehr
unsere kinder werden das alles bezahlen
müssen und deshalb rate ich dringend
dazu auch in der korona krise mit dem
geld der steuerzahler sorgfältig
umzugehen
unterbrechen sie sich einen zacken aus
der krone wenn sie wie jens spahn zu
geben dass man es hier und da
übertrieben hat es geht ja nicht um
kronen oder zocken sondern zunächst mal
war es ja so dass die größere selbst in
bayern um viele uns gefragt bitte
schließt es weil sie damals auch große
sorgen hatten wie die infektion sich
dort auswirken würde
natürlich ist heute das regionale
steuerungs modell das bessere aber eins
muss man schon sagen ich kann es
zumindest für den freistaat sagen wir
hatten damals wirklich extrem
ansteigende zahlen auch todesfälle und
die frage war
brechen wir diese welle versuchen wir
etwas sozusagen herumzuschrauben oder
brechen wir sie wirklich und ich kann
ihn hundertprozentig sagen welche
maßnahme genau die wichtigste und
entscheidendste aber das ist uns
gelungen ist das war glaube ich und da
sind wir uns ja alle einige deutschland
das entscheidende und das schicksal
anderer länder zu vermeiden
und wenn sie gerade eben vor dieser
sendung liefert das politbarometer wenn
sie die umfrage sehen der deutschen bahn
sind 87 prozent zufrieden oder wünschen
sich sogar noch konsequenteren maßnahmen
das heißt ich glaube wir befinden uns
das schon im einklang mit dem klaren
mehrheitswillen und zu befürchten so und
dann sind sie zurück in der runde heraus
gehen und das was die wirtschaft jetzt
am meisten braucht ist genau ein ende
der angst was sie braucht ist
planungssicherheit und genau die gibt es
aber nicht also mir scheint wenn man den
blick noch mal ganz kurz zurück wirft
dass es wichtig ist dass wir nicht immer
von einem lok da und reden denn was wir
hier in deutschland gesehen haben war
kein locker und sondern war ein relativ
relativ differenziertes maßnahmenbündel
was mit dem aus meiner sicht besten
wissen und gewissen auf das eingegangen
ist was ein gleichgewicht bedeutet
zwischen gesundheitsschutz einerseits
und und einem aufrechterhalten so weit
wie möglich so wirtschaftslebens
andererseits wir müssen wir denken dass
in ländern wie spanien italien
frankreich die produzierende industrie
komplett geschlossen wurde werden bei
uns die betriebe die das wollten und
konnten so wie zum beispiel das
unternehmen sich vertreter einig wir
haben weiter gearbeitet gekonnte ganze
zeit weiter arbeiten also wir hatten
keine lockdown trotzdem hoffen wir
natürlich dass die maßnahmen mit dem
wissen das jetzt zur verfügung steht
noch differenzierter auch noch
zielgenauer durchgeführt werden wenn ich
glaube tatsächlich dass es essentiell
ist dass wir die wirtschaften die
unterschiedlichen wirtschaftsbereichen
am laufen
verschiedene uns hart getroffen aber ich
glaube es gebrochen die sehr viel härter
getroffen sind das wie wo es wirklich
essentiell ist haben wir auch das ist
eine ganz ganz zielgenau sein ist
zielgenauer seien noch mal die frage an
den mediziner an denen hier weniger
entschuldigung herr zastrow es ist ja
von markus söder angesprochen
manche länder verschärften andere länder
lockern ist es einfach so
das ist alles nur keinen klaren plan
gibt wahrscheinlich da haben wir
wahrscheinlich noch den besten plan und
man muss sich ja immer wieder vor augen
halten oder fragen wo kommt das virus
eigentlich her und das kommt bei uns und
natürlich auch in spanien oder in
italien aus dem nasen-rachen-raum des
menschen es gibt keine andere
geheimnisvolle quelle wo man noch
forschen und suchen müsse
das ist alles klar der mund nasen
rachenraum ist die quelle und deswegen
brauchen wir die maske wenn die viren
nicht ausschalten maske auf und durch ja
ich sage auch da war es mehr
man kann natürlich auch noch mehr machen
man kann auch seinen mund desinfizieren
das ist ganz einfach und damit streut
man praktisch kaum noch wehren eine
mundspülung in regelmäßigen abständen
vernichtet die viren und dann haben wir
auch in der bevölkerung eine deutlich
niedrigere virus lasst die kollegen
virologen haben wir auch mit mann gesagt
ja die viruslast spielte eine rolle
dann frage ich mich warum sagen wenn ich
leute desinfiziert euch die münder
wir machen das in krankenhäuser machen
wir das schon seit april ja also das ist
jetzt nicht so ganz neu und die
desinfektionsmittel die schleimhaut
desinfektionsmittel verwendet sind 40
jahre alt das 650 und appetit das ist
aber ganz wichtig damit senken wir die
viruslast in der bevölkerung und dann
die maske auf und dann wird gar nichts
mehr passieren
also da haben wir nochmal einen
zusätzlichen hinweis nicht nur die maske
sondern auch schön gurgeln machen nach
der sendung und merken uns dann wird gar
nichts mehr passieren frau schnitzer was
ist das besondere dieser krise das
besondere ist
das ist produzenten und verbraucher
unverschuldet gleichermaßen trifft ist
das der große unterschied zu allen
anderen krisen zuvor
tatsächlich kann man dieses mal nicht
einen festmachen der etwas ausgelöst hat
so wie bei der finanzkrise
beispielsweise wo man tatsächlich sagen
konnte
die banken haben da ihren teil dazu
beigetragen insofern muss man an der
stelle eben auch gar keinen schuldigen
suchen man muss nur schauen wie alle am
besten raus kommen bei beckmann und bei
ihnen ist die frage im grunde genommen
schon beantwortet ihnen und ihrer
branche hat man das arbeiten verboten
ärgert es sie dass es in anderen
bereichen der vorzugsbehandlung gibt
beispielsweise im sport und beim fußball
naja das ärgert mich insofern dass wir
da keine möglichkeit haben
dementsprechend gerade zu intervenieren
bei uns dass die komplette
arbeitsgrundlage entzogen wurden das was
erlaubt ist ist faktisch
unwirtschaftlich das heißt wir verdienen
damit gerade kein geld und 242 legen
wenn noch obendrauf es höchstens ein
mehrwert für die wenigen leute der
gesellschaft die daran teilnehmen können
beziehungsweise wollen weil auch das
noch ein psychologischer faktor der zu
beachten ist und man muss auch einfach
mal sehen dass die gesellschaft auch ein
gewisses vermissen hat also es wird
wahrscheinlich keiner mit seiner frau
die ganze zeit zu hause tanzen wollen
das bezweifeln wir sehr stark das geht
jetzt auf markus söder an markus söder
hatte vorgeschlagen man soll besser zu
hause dann sinn wenn einem zum tanzen
ist dass er gut auf dauer nicht
funktionieren also man sieht jetzt auch
schon eine veranstaltung die zu nehmen
menschenansammlungen jetzt gerade bei
dem warmen wetter hat man es sehr
deutlich gesehen und das sind einfach
geschichten die sind einfach nicht
professionell gesteuert und mit
sicherheit eher gefährlich als
professionell geführte veranstaltungen
und da braucht man einfach auch
perspektiven aber in erster linie
brauchen wir gerade die wirtschaftliche
hilfe weil uns einfach die
arbeitsgrundlage komplett entzogen
werden
wir fragen gleich bei herrn scholz
vorher nochmal die frage an herrn
zastrow
herthas trug kneipen clubs große messen
events sind dass ereignisse die wir uns
in der zukunft sparen werden müssen naja
ich meine auch da wollen wir langsam zur
normalität zurück kommen ich sagte ja
schon es gibt keine neuen erkenntnisse
es ist alles das selbe geblieben wo das
virus herkommt natürlich sind die ganz
großen veranstaltungen wo wir auch
erwarten so oder wo ihr dann auch
verlangen dass masken getragen werden
schwer kontrollierbar in einer kneipe
ist es sicherlich auch er ein schlechter
witz wenn man immer vollen kneipe mit
nasenschutz rumlaufen muss das machen
wir auch jetzt schon nicht in den
restaurants sonst kriegen wir jetzt
essen nicht im mund also die das muss
man wirklich das sind die die die
regionalen gesichtspunkte wo die leute
jährige hygiene konzepte vorlegen müssen
die müssen natürlich auch mal vernünftig
geprüft werden von fachleuten von
hygieniker aber sie müssen natürlich
auch kontrolliert werden
ich habe das im urlaub erlebt da gibt es
restaurants trinken menschen hasst und
und irgendein nachbar restaurants da
wird's vorbildlich gemacht also da
verstehe ich dann die ordnungsbehörden
auch nicht die müssen da wirklich dafür
sorgen dass das umgesetzt wird wird dann
wäre das nicht umgesetzt wird dann ist
es ja so hatten wir gar nichts machen
ja dennoch ist natürlich die große frage
sind damit automatisch auch ganze
geschäftsfelder tod beispielsweise eben
bei der messe und in der event branche
da wäre es nicht besser wenn die
existenz von frau beckmann tatsächlich
ruiniert ist und das obwohl es
vielleicht gar nicht nötig ist weil das
sind professionelle veranstalter also
natürlich werde es nicht mehr wenn man
nicht gewünscht und dann sehr schlimm
deswegen hat ja auch gerade der bund
eine enorme zahl an hilfsinstrumenten
gegeben überbrückungshilfen soforthilfen
auch die andere von buffett struktur
ja es gibt eine reihe für unternehmen
gibt es eine reihe von ich kenne kann es
jetzt im einzelfall aus der ferne
bevergern aber es gibt eine fülle von
angeboten die gemacht wurden und die
auch in der praxis sehr viel helfen aber
dann war es eben auch wenn ich jetzt
sagen da wissen sie was mich so ein
bisschen auch um treibt jetzt auch wenn
wir das so diskutieren es ist
tatsächlich so dass wir die häuschen das
sehr klug bemerkt hat in deutschland
viel weniger hatten an einschränkungen
als überall sonst in der welt wir werden
erleben dass woanders die
einschränkungen wieder viel stärker
werden und warum nicht allein weil die
großen veranstaltungen professionell
organisiert ein problem sind sondern
viele private feiern wir nicht ständig
das sich an vorschriften nicht gehalten
würde mein appell einfach wenn ich das
sagen darf ist es geht tatsächlich am
ende schon auch um das leben von
menschen und ich bin nicht bereit
einfach nur zu sagen weil einige spaß
haben wollen
riskieren wir jetzt sei die gefahr von
menschenleben ist glaube ich in sachen
regung ist immer vorne dran zu stellen
noch mal dabei und wir bleiben aber man
beim thema von frau beckmann
herr scholz die frage ist ganz einfach
die sozialdemokraten setzen sich für die
arbeitnehmer in großen betrieben ein
aber für eine solo selbständige bleibt
hartz iv wir haben eine ganze reihe von
maßnahmen ergriffen für sehr sehr viele
unternehmen wir haben zuschuss programme
gemacht die auch in großem umfang in
anspruch genommen worden sind erstmal
unmittelbar in der krise wird jetzt
richtig zuschüsse für unternehmen auch
für kleine und für große wir haben das
mit der bergungs hilfe jetzt nochmal
erweitern wir sind gerade dabei das auch
über die jetzigen zeiträume zum
jahresende noch einmal zu verlängern und
die kriterien und die
zugangsmöglichkeiten zu erweitern für
diese überbrückung cell die
überbrückungshilfe und die das
statistische regierungsprogramm für die
steuerberater das ist ehrlicher weise
etwas was man sagen kann womit man der
sache aber nicht dient wir haben ja
letztendlich kann man muss ja im versand
wir müssen ja irgendwie zahlen haben und
deren basis wir jemanden der sagt da ist
mein konto ein betrag überweisen
50.000 200.000 euro die unbürokratische
nummer ist er sagt ich brauche die
200.000 er kriegt zu überwiesen wir
sagen ist ja schön wenn du sie nicht
mehr hass und wir sind sicherlich 200
jahren wieder
zum nichtstun verurteilt was mit der
messe und event orange geschieht wenn
man jemanden zum nichtstun verurteilt
kann dann mehr muss dann mehr übrig sein
als hallo hier
deshalb haben wir zuschüsse gegeben
kredithilfen haben kurzarbeit gemacht
war eine ja auch beschäftigte haben das
genutzt worden ist wir haben personal
kosten absetzbar gemacht das sind all
die dinge die wir jetzt auf den weg
gebracht haben und die auch helfen
sollen um durch diese krise zu kommen
und natürlich ist es so beschreiben dass
ja auch das ist ja auch alles sehr
begründet dass das situation geht
protest an
alles obwohl es so viel geld ist und wir
zig milliarden ausgeben hat den
unternehmen zu helfen auch den
unternehmen dann auch den kleinen
mittelständischen unternehmen nicht alle
probleme löst die da sind und ich finde
darüber sollte man auch nicht hinweg
reden und auch nicht so tun als ob sie
kein problem hätten sie haben ein
riesiges problem und sie können
überhaupt nichts dafür und ich glaube
das muss auch gesagt mein unternehmen
und die mittelständer sind quasi
schlüsselunternehmen in unserer
wirtschaft wenn die nicht gerettet
werden
dann haben wir insgesamt ein großes
problem so und da da muss man schon
ansetzen weil das ist in folge dessen
wenn die nicht mehr existieren auch ein
großes problem für alle kleineren
betriebe und viele solo selbstständigen
dies jetzt neumodischer weise heißt
haben sie jemals überbrückungsgeld
beantragt haben sie s bekommen in der
tat ich habe noch keinen zugang zu dem
nächsten hilfspaket weil die an
beantragung würde zu groß ist und das
erste überbrückungsgeld muss ich zu muss
man von nordrhein westfalen sagen die
soforthilfe war sehr schnell und auch
sehr unkompliziert gezahlt leider gottes
haben sich die akkus im laufe dieser
gesamten zeit genannt moore oft ja die
die einzige anhaltspunkte die einzelnen
landes punkte wo man schlussendlich mal
die idee bekommen hat für was sie
gedacht sind und die haben sich ständig
weiterentwickelt auch teilweise einfach
über nacht und schlussendlich ist es so
dass es komplett an der realität vorbei
ist das heißt diese soforthilfen helfen
gerade nicht weil das was an
betriebskosten da es wird eigentlich
nicht in voller anerkannt und das was
die selbständigen betrifft da sie haben
keinen platz
betriebskosten ist das herausgehen was
würden sie sagen ist dass das normale
risiko eine selbstständige also ich
glaube schon dass ich dieser blick auf
das einem geschäftsmodell innewohnte
risiko belohnt und der begriff der solo
selbstständigen den wir alle neu gelernt
haben wenn sie solo selbständige sind
dann haben sie natürlich ein risiko im
geschäftsmodell weil nämlich schon mal
alles von ihnen als person abhängt und
wenn sie als person ausfallen blickt ihr
geschäftsmodell zusammen oder wenn sie
krank werden da sonst was also sie haben
natürlich keine ausweichmöglichkeiten
sie können mit nicht spielen sie stehen
mit ihrer person im risiko und damit
wenn was schiefgeht wird sofort
existenziell und ich stelle mir schon
die frage inwieweit die verantwortung
des staates ist für das inhärente
risiken eines solchen geschäfts oder
einzustehen und ich glaube und damit
will ich gar nicht in den fall
beurteilen aber ich glaube wir müssen
schon darauf achtgeben dass das was
jetzt als corona hilfe ausgezahlt wird
auch tatsächlich eine krone spezifische
hilfe ist an die unternehmen und an die
menschen die von corona besonders hart
getroffen sind
wenn das bei einer selbständigen wie bei
ihnen der fall ist dann sollte es darf
ein instrument geben ich habe aber schon
auch die befürchtung dass unheimlich
viel geld im augenblick bei unternehmen
ankommen
die vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt von
corona so hart getroffen
der schub bringen genau ich darüber
reden wir gleich und zwar sofort und
auch ausführlich und trotzdem nochmal
zuvor beckmann
welche veranstaltungen welche messen
würden sie den momentan für möglich
halten und haben sie das gefühl mit
diesen verboten wird im grunde auch
willkürlich umgegangen
ich würde einmal kurz sonst möglich noch
mal darauf ist alle reden und zwar ist
es ja nicht mehr wirklich das
unternehmerische risiko
wir haben es ja nicht selber verursacht
wir zählt nicht mehr zum
unternehmerischen risiko und man kommt
aus eigener kraft da auch nicht mehr
raus und ja wir reden über länger
betroffene bereiche und wenn wir über
das geschäftsmodell reden gerade sind
auch hersteller aus unseren bereichen
ganz stark getroffen und die werden mit
sicherheit genauso lange wenn nicht
sogar noch länger getroffen sein als die
selbständigen die immer so nett als
letztes glied in der nahrungskette
bezeichnet werden weil momentan wir
können halt nichts veräußern unser
gebrauchtwarenmarkt das überschwemmt
aufgrund dessen dass die insel
wenn es wäre schon angefangen hat und
unserer wirtschaft und der wird nicht
leer gekauft und es ist auch gerade
keine kaufkraft da und das was wir an
krediten kriegen können wir nicht
wertschöpfend investieren also sprich
wir können auch gerade nur mit diesen
krediten für eine gewisse zeit überleben
da ist auch die laufzeit der kredite
definitiv ein problem da muss man noch
mal ansetzen und dann seid ihr doch sie
über dieses stichwort angst der
nachfrage was hielten sie für möglich
weil sie einfach sagen sie sind
professionelle veranstaltungsmanager und
der müsste es genauso möglich sein 500
und 1000 leute in einer messe
ordnungsgemäß zu überwachen mit den
entsprechenden sicherheitsvorkehrungen
ja also ich würde mir ganz stark
wünschen und da appelliere ich auch
gerne ansehe und auch an alle kollegen
dass wir vernünftige konzepte darlegen
können die auch akzeptabel sind wonach
wir wieder eine chance kriegen ein
wiedereinstieg zu haben weil natürlich
hier sind gerade außer gefecht gesetzt
zum schutz der bevölkerung wird tragen
diese maßnahmen auch gerne mit weil wenn
unser job in anführungsstrichen menschen
gefährden sollte dann ist es nicht unser
ansinnen uns das unbedingt durchzusetzen
um auch nochmal auf den sensor dazu
sprechen zu kommen
wir wollen das ganze mit verstand und
mit der höchstmöglichen sicherheit
machen und wir wollen natürlich weil man
im wohnzimmer tanzen ist auch nicht
wirtschaftlich arbeitet auch irgendwann
wieder selber in eigene wirtschaftliche
tätigkeit kommen halt eben nicht auf
dauer auf die hilfe der ist noch mal die
frage sie haben aber milliarden auf der
rechnung
ist das auch alles deshalb so teuer weil
die politik ist einfach mit verboten
übertrieben hat und zwar aus angst vor
diesen nein das glaube ich nicht
ich finde dass wir ziemlich gut durch
die krise gekommen sind gerade wenn man
das international vergleicht und das uns
auch sehr hilft dass wir in deutschland
föderales land sind persönlich haben an
vielen veranstaltungen teilgenommen wo
sich die bundesregierung und die
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsidenten
lang darüber unterhalten haben er hat
aus meiner sicht zu besseren ergebnissen
geführt als in anderen ländern
sie haben es eben gesagt herr häuschen
es ist so dass in vielen ländern die
produktion stillgelegt worden ist das
haben wir in deutschland praktisch gar
nicht gemacht aber hier sind
professionelle veranstaltung
nochmal zu deutlicher genau zu dieser
frage kommen sie um zwei jungen musste
beide wagen wurden
es ist das erst und das was diese frage
betrifft müssen wir das jetzt immer ganz
genau mitbekommen weil wir das in diesen
runden diskutieren und ich kann ihnen
sagen ich interessiere mich kennen wir
auch noch viele andere für die ganz
konkreten konzepte die da sind
denn wir werden ja solange wir keine
therapie und keinen impfstoff haben so
wie hast du das ja auch schildert einen
weg finden müssen wie wir mit dem virus
umgehen können und das heißt wir müssen
jetzt auch stück für stück lernen falls
das sehr lange dauert das wir nicht
alles wieder so machen können wie das
vorher der fall war wie das funktioniert
das zum beispiel ihr geschäft
funktioniert ab sowohl das virus noch
nicht gesichtet was muss die auch
jahrelang haben dass das gleiche gilt
für die schausteller und übrigens ein
teil der änderung wird diese gesprochen
haben sind immer das ergebnis von
solchen vorschlägen von einzelnen
berufsgruppen die gesagt haben
damit es auf uns passt müssen wir das
noch machen und das haben wir auch
versucht jeweils hinzukriegen
ich will nicht behaupten dass wir jetzt
in allen punkten perfekt gewesen sind
aber da ist unglaublich viel mühe dabei
zu versuchen jedem ganz konkret zu
helfen denn das ist etwas was ich mit
ihnen teilen
sie können für diese krise da nichts
erreichen aber erheblich darunter das
haben sie auch einen anspruch auf die
solidarität von uns anderen und die
unterstützung und wenigstens bei
überbrückungsgeld soll was passieren
halten wir das an der stelle schon mal
fest und sagen auch in der großen
wirtschaft in der industrie trifft ist
natürlich nicht alle gleich und manche
trifft ist knüppelhart
sie zeigten uns die welt sie brachten
uns freude
sie waren das rückgrat unserer
volkswirtschaft
diese drei branchen gehören jetzt zu den
großen corona verlierern
fernreisen werden gecancelt den
massentourismus ist kaum noch gefragt
partys und events wie früher gibt es
nicht mehr
hotels und gastronomie sind in der
existenz bedroht
autokonzerne und zulieferer sind das
mark der deutschen wirtschaft jetzt
steckt die branche tief in der krise
bei markus söder in bayern sind 92
prozent dieser betriebe in kurzarbeit
auch die maschinenbauer stecken tief in
der korona krise die produktion bricht
um 17 prozent ein in diesem jahr der
niedrigste stand seit neun jahren
68 prozent der betriebe nutzen
kurzarbeit das trifft jeden dritten
beschäftigten bis jahresende werden wohl
40.000 arbeitsplätze gestrichen
da sind die restlichen zahlen des vdm a
herr häuschen
sie haben kurzarbeit schon erwähnt 17
prozent einbruch der produktion die
politik kümmert sich um die großen
kümmert sich um vw und bmw um daimler
ist diese fürsorge für die großen
konzerne in ihren augen berechtigt über
die fürsorge über die großen konzerne
für die großen zahlen könnte man jetzt
lange philosophieren
es ist auch nicht so dass jetzt für die
mittelgroßen betrieb nichts getan wurde
also aus sicht unserer branche kann ich
sagen dass die hilfen schnell und
weitestgehend sachgerecht für unsere
branche gestaltet worden sind bei den
großen konzernen kann ich mir schon
vorstellen das ein oder andere
vielleicht vorher schon eine
strukturkrise drin war und die krone
helfen vielleicht eher dazu dienen das
ein oder andere problem zu strecken oder
zu überdecken aber das muss ich jedes
betroffene unternehmen selber fragen
da ist er sehr vorsichtig dazu kommen
wir gleich noch mit frau schnitzer ist
diese situation jetzt frau schmitz ja
eigentlich eine in der es besonders in
dieser akuten krise in der
besonders richtig und wichtig ist auf
modernisierung zu drängen
auch um den preis von insolvenzen 12 ja
unbedingt wir haben ja drei gruppen von
unternehmen die betroffen sind das in
einmal die die durch die krise betroffen
sind wie die eventbranche die nichts
dafür können wo das geschäftsmodell aber
nicht kaputt ist das wird nach der krise
wieder laufen
dann haben wir branchen wo sich
tatsächlich durch die krise auch etwas
verändern wird luftfahrtbranche
beispielsweise wir werden nicht so
schnell zu den zahlen von vorher kommen
es war richtig die lufthansa zu retten
aber da wird das arbeitsplätze abgebaut
werden arbeitsplätze abgebaut werden
müssen und da führt auch kein weg dran
vorbei und dann gibt es eben branchen wo
schon vorher der strukturwandel
offensichtlich angezeigt war der aber
von manchen unternehmen nicht heran
getrieben worden ist wie es nötig
gewesen wäre
da denken wir jetzt beispielsweise an
die automobilbranche aber der
einzelhandel hat ähnliche probleme der
wird ja durch die online durch den
online handel massiv bedrängt und in
diesen branchen ist jetzt einfach
notwendig dass man in die zukunft
investiert und nicht durch maßnahmen wie
denken wir an kaufprämien oder durch
maßnahmen wie jetzt wollen wir den
klimaschutz mal ein bisschen zurück
stellen dass man durch solche maßnahmen
die modernisierung aufhält und das
befürchten sie durch eine verlängerung
dieses kurzarbeitergeldes das ist bei
herrn häuschen auch schon angedeutet in
der tat also kurzarbeitergeld heißt ja
dass man die menschen länger an das
unternehmen bindet das ist kurzfristig
sehr gut so weil man ja die menschen
binden möchte die sich im unternehmen
auskennen um deren deren arbeitskraft
man zu schätzen gelernt hat aber wenn
sich das zu lange hinzieht dann ist es
auch wichtig dass die sich neu
orientieren und da hilft übrigens auch
gar nicht dass man jetzt verlängert hat
mit den sehr hohen bezügen von 80
prozent mit familie 87 prozent das ist
gerade das verkehrte man sollte es
umgekehrt machen erst viel geld und dann
mit der zeit weniger sodass man auch ein
anreiz hat sich neu zu orientieren
in der cdu und in der fdp herr söder
befürchten manche das corona die
planwirtschaft durch die hintertür
wieder einführt und sie fordern jetzt
sogar
hilfe für die luftfahrt und die
autobauer und den maschinenbau sind sie
in corona sozialist oder wenn sie jetzt
aber die erste nämlich so bezeichnet das
gegenteil ist der fall ich glaube dass
wir klug in deutschland bislang agiert
haben wir waren das auch weiter tun
müssen um zu überlegen wie können wir
unsere möglich im besten sinne
verstandene industriepolitik weiter
fortsetzen und dazu gehört nun einmal
dass wir uns überlegen müssen wir vitale
industrie bereiche stärken können dazu
gehört einerseits den forschungssektor
noch einmal massiv zu beschleunigen
das beispiel was jetzt in bayern mit der
massive ausbau von künstlicher
intelligenz der universitäten
wasserstofftechnologie quanten forschung
also der ganze bereich dessen was die
transaktion beschleunigt die zukunft ist
ja findet ihr jetzt schon statt also
wenn wir das was frau professor gerade
gesagt hat ernst nehme dann tun wir das
genau setzen so müsste es eine und des
zweites wir haben beispielsweise bei der
beim automobil bei den elektroautos
enorm prämien eingesetzt haben sie sogar
verdoppelt auf vorschlag den wir dann ja
dann im koalitionsausschuss beschlossen
haben waren herr scholz du nicht auch
gemeinsam dabei und das wirkt ja auch
die leute kaufen jetzt mehr elektroautos
insofern müssten uns auch überlegen ob
es bei nutzfahrzeugen ist entsprechende
unterstützung zu geben flotten zu
erneuern beispielsweise staatlich oder
kommunal und das gleiche gilt auch
beispielsweise für die übergangsweise
für die modernsten und besten verbrenner
der welt denn die autos beispielsweise
die wir im diesel jetzt haben die jetzt
gerade produziert wenn
produktionsstandorte wenn er normal
beitrag für den klimaschutz
und deswegen glaube ich müssen wir uns
dann nochmal genau überlegen welche
impulse wir setzen können um dort
veränderungen zu schaffen und auch
unsere eigene industrie und die eigenen
arbeitsplätze zu halten denn das sorgt
schon die aufgabe jetzt hast du es ist
ja eine völlig absurde situation kann
man sagen dass über erfolg oder
misserfolg im wettbewerb im grunde das
lokale infektionsgeschehen entscheidet
ja sicherlich wird es genauso sein oder
wird stark darauf einfluss nehmen und
denn wir wollen jetzt also lokale lockt
das machen wir wollen also einzelne
betriebe schließen und nicht gleich das
ganze land dicht machen
das ist ja auch der richtige weg ich
glaube auch das hat mir ein pädagogisch
didaktische pädagogisch didaktischen
effekt damit man auch wirklich dann
sieht aber wer sich falsch verhält
er hatte wird eben in dieser weise
bestraft und wieder setzt er in garmisch
auch war die empörung der bevölkerung
bei auch entsprechend groß zum glück ist
doch nicht allzu viel passiert
aber natürlich sind solche kleinen in an
14 kleinen ereignisse maßgeblich auch
dafür ob ja wie es weitergeht oder ob
wir vielleicht sogar eigentlich dann
darauf verzichten können große geschütze
aufzufahren also das wäre leicht möglich
fragen mundspülung der rolle werden wir
herr scholz wir nehmen das argument von
herrn häuschen auf der staat hat
schwierigkeiten zu entscheiden welche
unternehmen eine zukunft haben also
stützt ist stützt der staat in der krise
erst mal alle unternehmen ist es jetzt
an der zeit sich vermehrt um einzelne
branchen zu kümmern
wir haben ja der zielgerichtete
programme wickelt aber eins muss man
auch sagen wir haben bei einem großen
teil der programme die wir auf den weg
gebracht haben hrt um das ist vor der
krise keine probleme gab also die großen
eigenkapitalhilfen die wir mit dem
wirtschaft zum stabilisierungsfonds
machen wo ja ein riesige menge geld auf
die bücher des bundes zu kommt wo wir
die garantien gegeben haben dürfen wir
auch mit der eu vereinbart nur
unternehmen für unternehmen bei dem
vorher keine das ist das was auch stück
für stück fall für fall jemals
betrachtet wird das kann man aber nicht
bei jedem kleinen unternehmen machen die
müssen schon eine gewisse größenordnung
haben sonst hätten wir ja gar nicht die
möglichkeit das zu prüfen und müssen und
sich das zweite sind weiß heute was mir
ganz wichtig ist ist dass wir mit den
entscheidungen die wir auf den weg
gebracht haben versuchen jeweils die
spezifische situation der einzelbranchen
zu unterstützen wir haben
exportförderung und der erleichterung
gemacht für die exportierende industrie
der maschinenbau exportiert etwa 80
prozent das ist dort wichtig sie haben
sichergestellt dass es die möglichkeit
gibt
neue anschaffung zu machen und die
besonders abzuschreiben so dass wir
unternehmen dazu verleiten so ableiten
abzuschreiben wir immer abgeschrieben
worden sind wir hatten jetzt
zwischendrin eine ab nummer li und jetzt
sind wir wieder so sehe ich das anders
erzählt sie aber jedenfalls sehr gut an
die massiven förderung die wir genau in
diesen jahren jetzt einsetzen
und dann haben wir entschieden dass wir
ganz konkret programme auf den weg
bringen die den unternehmen dabei helfen
dass sie die zukunftsaufgaben jetzt
anpacken können da geht es dann um die
förderung von digitalisierungs maßnahmen
da geht es um den ausbau der
forschungsförderung auch steuerlich was
wir noch mal erweitert haben da geht es
um die frage der künstliche intelligenz
da geht es um den industriellen einstieg
in die wasserstoffwirtschaft die
fahrerin soll ja schon mal ganz konomen
aller die ganztags in ordnung reagiert
wenn das sind ja alles ganz großer
unterschied ich ihnen wenn ich das kurz
sagen dazu
die haben nämlich gesagt also anders
über da helfen aber wir verbinden das
auch mit zukunfts maßnahmen damit diese
zeit genutzt werden kann von unternehmen
gewissermaßen gestärkt aus dieser sehr
schwierigen situation heraus lief er
heiß geht ich wollte noch mal auf die
verlängerung des kurzarbeitergeldes com
dies ist eine wichtige frage weil da
sind die meinungen auch dass es gibt
eine angst vor so genannten zombie
unternehmen das unternehmen am markt
noch gehalten werden künstlich beatmet
werden künstlich finanziert werden
obwohl sie eigentlich schon todkrank
sind
befürchten sie dass das der fall ist und
können die auch selbst kerngesunde
unternehmen mit in die krise gezogen wie
unternehmen ist um so ein drama begriff
den will ich jetzt mal vermeiden
es ist sicherlich das risiko dass durch
die eine oder andere hilfe unternehmen
die nicht wenn eine ausreichend
wettbewerbsfähig sind
ich sage es mal nicht notwendig gestützt
werden
es gibt unternehmen die vielleicht ihr
geschäftsmodell nicht schnell genug
angepasst haben die vielleicht trends
der digitalisierung nicht rechtzeitig
erkannt haben die vielleicht bestimmte
mobilitätsformen nicht rechtzeitig
erkannt haben und wo jetzt corona hilfen
genutzt werden um einen sowieso schon
mal laden zustand zu strecken
und da ist natürlich bedauerlich und es
ist schon erstaunlich wie schnell manche
unternehmen die kurze welt gegangen sind
in die krone kurzarbeit kaum dass jene
verkündet war
ja das stimmt beispielsweise vw
ja unter anderem also wieder ob im
einzelhandel oder in der autoindustrie
da sind wir noch mal beim thema wird
corona einfach auch als ausrede benutzt
um eigene versäumnisse zu übertünchen
oder die zu verschieben es gibt
sicherlich schwächen und es gab auch
schon viele vorher
sie haben mir einige auch benannt das
ist ganz klar deswegen ist ja auch zum
beispiel so dass in der
automobilindustrie
das heutige management nicht das gleiche
wie zu dem zeitpunkt als manches
versäumnis passiert ist also es hat ja
da innere extreme strukturveränderung
gegeben
neue justierungen neue
transformationsprozesse die frage ist
jetzt dabei die begleiten wir das ganze
also wie begleiten wir dass es geht
nicht tatsächlich unternehmen am leben
zu halten die sonst am markt überhaupt
keine chance hätten aber es kommt schon
darauf an die struktur als ganzes zur
klappte es doch dass unternehmer als
rheins ist sondern die struktur
insgesamt zu stärken oder ist ihnen in
die branchen von den wir reden schon
sehr wichtig ich würde jetzt nicht
unbedingt dem begriff cologne als
sozialistisch sozialist erteilen herr
söder aber vielleicht kroner die
register die frage ist schon inwieweit
es sage ich jetzt mal sei es auf
landesebene sei als auf bundesebene
politik möglich ist zu beurteilen ob
jetzt ein bestimmtes unternehmen oder
eine bestimmte branche oder ein
bestimmtes produkt eine förderung
braucht aber die anderen uns doch darauf
sehr eindeutig nein das können wir genau
deshalb im rahmen bedenken ist dass
gegen iran wieder die damen für gesundes
wirtschaften ist keine hilfe darauf
ausgerichtet dass irgendwo ein beamter
sitzt er entscheidet dieses unternehmen
hat in der zukunft und dieses ist nicht
das wäre eine furchtbare situation und
würde auch die leistungsfähigkeit
unserer volkswirtschaft erheblich
beeinträchtigen was wir aber machen
können ist seit so durch die zeit zu
helfen und gleichzeitig
zukunftsprogramme damit zu verbinden und
ich will noch mal etwas sagen
von beckmann noch ganz einsatz zur
kurzarbeit
da wird auch viel hinein geheimnis wenn
ich das mal dazu sagen darf ein
unternehmen das ein personalabbau
abbauen muss weil ich kann verwendung
mehr hat und macht kurzarbeit
schadet sich wirtschaftlich das nutzt um
gewissermaßen sich vor der entscheidung
zu drücken
trifft eine falsche entscheidung und
deshalb ist die kurzarbeit nach meinen
erfahrungen früher als anwalt
zwischendurch mal als arbeitsminister
und jetzt in den funktionen die ich
jetzt habe eigentlich ein sehr
zielgerichtet des instrumentes
missbrauch kennt sich ja aber nicht viel
nicht viele fragen wir gleich von
schnitzler vorher möchte ich von frau
beckmann noch wissen ist es richtig wenn
die politik versucht jeden job in diesem
land zu retten
also grundsätzlich befürworte ich erst
mal das instrument kurzarbeit war dass
es mit sicherheit das beste instrument
was uns in dieser krise speziell bei der
veranstaltungsbranche wo ich jetzt von
reden kann am schnellsten weitergeholfen
hat aber ich bin da ganz bei anderen
meinungen hier auch das bestimmt viele
das auch einfach ganz schnell beantragt
haben und eingesetzt haben wo es nicht
wirklich zielführend ist
man muss aber auch mal feststellen dass
es doch eine enorme schieflage gerade
gibt in der handlung der politik an
vielen stellen ganz speziell was jetzt
auf den automobilbereich angeht weil
wenn ich jetzt einfach mal sehr dass da
jetzt schon zum zweiten mal angesetzt
wird und bei uns unternehmen die im
rating vorher deutlich höher waren als
daimler beispielsweise hier komplett vor
die wand gefahren werden weil einfach an
der wirtschaft bei uns nicht
zielgerichtete hilfe ankommt das finde
ich doch höchst bedauerlich und da finde
ich dass es nicht gleichgültig sein sie
das ist ein unternehmen unserer branche
das kann ich gerne hinterher noch mal
weil sie erzählen können wir ja auch
noch mal nach brackley ich weiß jetzt
nicht aus dem kraftvoll schnitt wir sind
bei der entscheidenden frage was
bedeutet es diese situation mit einem
kurzarbeitergeld zu verlängern sie haben
schon gesagt dass sie es eigentlich
nicht gut finden wenn das jetzt noch bis
ende 21 geht weil man damit tatsächlich
eben auch unternehmen am leben hält die
sich verabschieden müsste vom markt aber
wir reden ja weiter von menschen die
eigentlich nichts dafür können auch von
arbeitnehmern die nichts dafür können
aber diese menschen ist sehr viel mehr
geholfen wenn es neue arbeitsplätze gibt
und deswegen muss man alles verhindern
was den strukturwandel aufhält und da
sehe ich aktuell die große gefahr dass
man die korona krise also ausrede nutzt
und dann auch manche rahmenbedingungen
wieder zurückzudrehen
zwei beispiele nennen das eine ist wir
hören vom verband der automobil
unternehmer es droht uns die
deindustrialisierung wenn wir nicht
verhindern dass das was brüssel sich das
vorstellt an klima auf vorgaben die und
weise zu verschaffen wenn wir das nicht
verhindern
das ist eine panikmache denn bei der
industrialisierung denkt jeder um gottes
willen das muss in zukunft wieder unsere
eigenen kartoffeln anbauen das ist aber
gar nicht das was uns droht also das ist
völlig unrealistisch und von daher auch
einfach aufhalten des strukturwandels
für ein anderes beispiel nennen
es wird aktuell ein ein gesetzesvorhaben
vorbereitet frauenquote in vorständen
die beiden ministerinnen gefallen und
lambrecht bereiten das vor und jetzt
hört man beispielsweise aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium zu zeiten von
corona können wir uns das gar nicht
leisten
man wird also jetzt zwei dinge
klimaschutz können wir uns nicht leisten
frauen in führungspositionen können wir
uns nicht leisten und da frage ich mich
wirklich ist dass die belastung oder ist
das nicht vielmehr die chance wenn man
also beide themen und jetzt als
belastung sieht dann trage ich schon